first of all it's inconceivable me that
we be at that point because the first
time they put up a barricade and my
police couldn't go in would be the last
time they did it and they'd all be
sitting in jail can you talk a little
bit about the tension that exists right
now between the New York Police
Department and de Blasio cuz I've got a
couple contacts there who I mean they're
ready to revolt against the guy like it
is a extraordinary mess right now
they believe that his incompetence puts
their lives at risk they believe that
his big mouth is condemning of them this
goes back to the very beginning with two
police officers called Ramos and Liu
when they were riots in Baltimore and de
Blasio shooting his big mouth off said
something about our Police Department
also having problems and racism he
didn't reflect on the fact that his
Police Department is not a majority
white police department anymore that
combination of Dinkins Koch and me we
gave Lumbergh a non majority anything
Police Department and Bloomberg made it
even better and we were all pretty proud
of that but instead of made making that
point which might have helped keep the
problem away from us he wants to put us
in with you know it's the wrong racist
Police Department's races please do but
within a few days of that a crazy man
from Baltimore comes up to New York two
police officers Romulus and Lewis
sitting there guarding a housing
development protecting black people and
the guy puts a bullet in the back of
both of the heads though the police
department surmised whether fair or not
is why would he have thought in New York
his big mouth hadn't made this statement
and that's the time they turned their
back on him told them they didn't want
him coming to the Pharaoh didn't want
him coming to the and then it's been a
series of unfortunate statements that
he'll say he had
teaches done how to deal with the danger
presented to him by the New York City
Police Department he didn't mention the
fact that he really should have taught
us on how to deal with the danger
presented him by other black young men I
mean the police department is chance of
being touched by the police department
in comparison of being killed by a black
man in New York you know is is less than
1% as opposed to 75% of the murder
victims in New York City are black and
75% of the murderers a black so I mean
you got to be a stupid father just to
train your fault it's done to worry
about the police one by a factor of
about fifty to one he's much more likely
to be killed by another young black man
do you think the average New Yorker is
waking up to this and seeing the chaos
on the streets and and everything you're
talking about
yeah yeah do you think a Republican or a
conservative could ever win in New York
again we're at the point where
Republican independent or reformed
Democrat you know somebody that's
completely removed from the political
machine yeah it's so helpful that I
could not have done what I did in New
York I'd have been a Democrat I hadn't I
owe no one a John thing nothing like I
could get rid of twenty thousand people
in city government and the unions could
go crazy
none of them supported me I didn't
expect them to support me in the future
I think I would have done it anyway but
I'm not sure takes a lot of courage to
do that but I had to make so few
compromises if any to become mayor that
then I guess I didn't think I'd even be
me so I was like free as a bird to do
what I wanted and the few people that
did help me they really were helping me
because they were so fed up with the
city the one thing they wanted from me I
knew if I reduce crime I was gonna be a
successful mayor I knew I was a
one-issue man I also knew if I didn't
reduce crime they'd throw me out
now we turned out to do a lot of other
things we reduced welfare by 600,000
people we got rid of homelessness we set
up a whole new thing for administration
the Children's Services and dealt with
domestic violence much much better than
ever before and we reduced taxes by
thirty five percent which had never been
done in New York City my first tax
reduction was only three percent my
deputy mayor came to me and he said May
instead of record for tax reduction
computer that's impossible only three
percent and then my he was my best
friend he also left it means that it's
only tax reduction ever even LaGuardia
was the liberal that tells you
everything we did a lot of things but
the the crime reduction was the thing
that made everything possible once they
saw we could do the impossible they had
confidence in us to do the normal
political things that could be done if
you were mayor of Seattle right now and
there was an autonomous zone or whatever
they're calling it gets renamed every
day right but there was a zone in your
city that was in effect a lawless zone
that police cannot go to in any
effective way that you know people can
do whatever they want they've taken over
stores and public parks and everything
else what would you do today because the
mayor in effect she's basically saying
it's lawful it's fine and Trump's stay
out of the way and in many ways I think
she's trying to set up I think between
her and Inslee the the governor of
Washington they're trying to set up a
trap they're showing hey we progressives
let anyone do whatever they they want so
the whole place is gonna crumble and
trump's gonna have to send in troops or
the National Guard or something and then
they'll say see he's the exact
authoritarian we always said he was well
what what do you were the mayor the
first of all it's inconceivable to me
that we'd be at that point because the
first time they put up a barricade and
my police couldn't go in would be the
last time they get it there I'll be
sitting in jail now though they wouldn't
be around if I had to come in now if
they put me in charge of that city right
now with the barricades there I would
make an assessment of what I
to get rid of them and I would get rid
of them at the earliest possible moment
and I would tell them I think if I were
you I would leave because this could be
much more pleasant if you leave than if
I have to make you leave but don't don't
mess around with me because I'm not
joking I'm not one of these silly wussy
liberal mayor like make my day give me a
chance to get you out of there and I'll
get you out of there you're not paying
taxes
you're not helping my city the smoking
dope like crazy maybe I'd sent DEA in
first and wipe out the drug deal then I
get about half of them out and it'd be
easier in fact think maybe if I were the
US Attorney there I would send the Drug
Enforcement Administration in and do a
major raid and get all the cocaine meth
marijuana
I know it's legal in Washington not
legal in the United States of America
somehow I do know my favorite deal with
organized crime you got to take
advantage of laws like the tax evasion
laws and in order to accomplish
something but if you want to make the
problem easier for the uniformed police
love is they don't take a look at all
the federal crimes they're committing
and go in and go in with a federal task
force and arrest them Drug Enforcement
Administration's a tough outfit I'd you
know I don't think they've encountered
something like David police by the
Seattle police they haven't encountered
the Drug Enforcement Administration yeah
I want a shift animal so I want a shift
to Trump a little bit because obviously
you guys are friends you have a history
so I want to know a little bit about
just the history of when he was just a
real-estate developer before he was even
a reality TV host but what that was like
when you were mayor and you knew him but
also I mentioned this to you last week
that the when I was at Marlo go right
before Christmas you guys were sitting
at the table right next to us
unfortunately I didn't get to say hi to
you but this was right when impeachment
was blowing up and everybody in the news
was saying the walls are closing in
Trump's freaking out this whole thing
but I'm watching the - you had a corner
of my eye
Trump has no tie on you guys are
laughing up a storm having a ball and
everybody saying the guy's freaking out
and then I had a very nice day Dave what
can you just talk a little bit about
Trump well first of all he never freaked
out during the whole experience
there's even an article in The
Washington Post you want to talk about
fake news there's an articles at one day
Jay Sekulow who is my co-counsel and I
were there with with several other
lawyers and the president had lost it
and he started throwing papers around
and he threw something at Jane Raskin
who was one of our lawyers and I kept
back we get back to our office and the
Washington Post has disbarred
well first of all he didn't throw
anything around number two Jane wasn't
even at the meeting there were no women
at the meeting but the report have
wanted it that he liked he assaulted a
woman would have been I said why don't
you make any threw it at me at least I
was there he didn't throw it at me but
you can see there but they don't they
don't like they don't like they just
throw something at you they made up yeah
I mean you can't believe how cynical I
became if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop yelling
check out our politics playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlist all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell